- You know him from Magic
Mike, 21 Jump Street,
and possibly that sex
dream you had last night.
That's right, that's right.
Give it up for Channing Tatum, everybody.
(soft melodic music)
(audience yells and claps)
- Hello!
- Hi. How are you?
- I am so good but you look like somewhere
wonderful behind you.
I want to be where you're at.
- Ah, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that looks awesome.
(Channing laughs)
- Come on over. We could-
- I'm like, it looks like
I want to take a walk
in your garden or your park behind you.
I don't know what's happening,
but why did you think...
'cause you're such a fitness guy.
What did you think of Meg's Fitness Story?
It's pretty incredible, right?
- Unreal. I mean, look, as
someone that has to work out
as for a job, I promise you
I would not look like this
unless I had to be naked in
most of my movies mostly.
And like, at some point I
got to get better at acting,
so I don't have to be
naked in all of them,
(Kelly laughs)
but she is just incredible.
I mean, I literally get
to work out as a job
and it's still hard.
And I can't imagine people
that have a nine to five job,
have kids at home, and then
where do they get the energy
and the time to actually, you
know, focus on themselves.
And I just think it's really
beautiful what she's done.
- Absolutely. And you get it, you're dad,
it's like there's a lot of time for work,
and then you're a dad,
It's like, it's a lot,
like to fit everything in.
Do you do like massive cheat days?
'Cause Dwayne Johnson was on here
and he showed me his
cheat day and I was like,
first of all, I would barf if I ate all
the things he ate on his cheat day.
But do you have massive ones?
- I sometimes do, not like massive ones.
'Cause I think as I'm getting older,
it's really getting, like
everything I pick up,
I just go, Oh, that's like two more miles
that I have to run or ride,
(Kelly laughs)
and it's like, I just
started looking at things
like they're just actual miles,
and time that I have to work out.
So I will pick the day and I
will pick very specific things.
I love cake.
- Oh my God, me too.
- But yeah, it's-
(Channing laughs)
- Oh my God.
And you just had a birthday.
We were birthdays near each other.
I'm the 24th and you're
the 26th right, of April?
- Of course, man.
We are absolutely-
- We are running the world.
- Yeah, I just had it, just had it.
- I don't know one Taurus
that doesn't love cake.
I'm just saying Lester's
birthday is today,
and he loves cake.
I'm just saying, but he also-
- Is that a cake thing?
Is that a Taurus thing?
- I think so I'm owning it.
I'm claiming it, it's not my fault.
I was born into this.
(Kelly laughs)
I was born this way, Gaga.
So how did you celebrate?
- We really did, like we chilled.
I think even during
quarantine like last year,
it was just a really
chill sort of birthday.
And we just sat around the pool,
we sidewalk chucked my driveway,
we have a giant wolf
that looks like it's...
we traced all the light
shadows from the trees
and it looks like this wolf on fire.
It's like a Wolf Walker on fire wolf,
that has like chicken
legs for some reason.
I don't know why.
- Oh my God, I love it.
- I think neither one of my daughter
or I knew how to draw wolf feet,
so we just went with chicken.
- Oh my gosh. Have you
seen the thing on Netflix?
I think it's called like
Wolf Walker or something.
My kids were obsessed with it.
I can't remember the name of it
but it won all these awards.
It was so good but then-
- It's so good that that's our
favorite movie at the moment.
Same filmmaker as Song of the Sea,
which you should definitely see the music,
and it is just outstanding.
- Oh, wow! I started watching
one last night with my kids
and I was like, "Is this the same people
that made the wolf one?"
And anyway, I've seen it so many times,
- Yeah.
- Is it true though that
your first big challenge
with fatherhood was
learning how to braid hair?
- Yeah. I completely
panicked when I found out
we were having a girl and I
literally went to YouTube,
and started figuring out like how...
I think the first one I
saw was a dad vacuuming up
his daughter's hair with like
a hair tie on to the vacuum.
And I was like, that's genius.
And then it doesn't work
like the guy did it.
I tried it and it didn't work as well.
But yeah, so I learned how to braid hair,
the hardest thing though,
'cause my daughter has
really straight, fine hair,
I have to do this every night
or she wakes up with a rat's nest.
It's like a giant, not back there.
But the hardest thing
'cause she has layered hair,
is doing the three, close
to the head, equal strands.
- [Kelly] Yup.
- You know, once I got that,
the braiding's easy.
The braiding's really, really simple,
but I'll get like three or
a third of the way through,
and I'll realize that one strand
is a lot shorter than the other one,
and my OCD kicks in and
I have to like restart,
and then it's just terrible.
- I know, God bless
sports for me on that one.
We all used to braid each
other in volleyball and soccer,
all those sports, I learned
that at a very young age.
(audience claps)
- His new children's
book is called, "The One
and Only Sparkella,"
and it's out right now.
But have you always wanted
to write a kid's book?
'Cause I didn't think one.
I'd ever have a kid and then I had kids,
and then I was like, oh,
it'd be fun to write a book,
you know, you're reading them
all the time with your kids,
and I ended up doing it too.
Is that kind of how it happened for you?
- Sort of. I mean, I never thought
I'd be an author of anything.
- Me neither.
- Much less like a kids book.
And, but like what
you're saying, you know,
you definitely end up
reading almost all of them.
You were looking for any suggestions
'cause we read five books every night.
All my friends were like, "You read five?
That was a horrible idea.
Why didn't you just say it's one book?"
And I was like, it's too late, we started,
we started with five already,
it's not the guys cast.
So we were reading
everything under the sun,
and then I definitely realized that
there weren't that many
dad-daughter books.
There was a kind of a hole in the market.
There was a lot of mom-kid
books and certain other ones,
and I just sort of was like,
you know, I don't know.
I wanted to write something that was very,
just me and my daughter have a
really beautiful relationship
and it was really fun.
And, you know, I was worried,
I was worried a little bit.
It was just how being a dad
of how was I going to relate
and understand a little girl.
And the key was just to go into
her world and it was so fun,
and the world that we created was so rich,
and like the characters, and the voices,
and the things was so much fun.
And she's such a little
character that I don't know.
The story just sort of happened.
I didn't really have to like
dig deep for the imagination.
It was more-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- it was more just observing my daughter,
and really just our relationship
is super hilarious to me.
- Yeah. If you're anything
like the father in that book,
you're awesome and you're nailing it.
It was the tutu and how you were coming,
and my kids loved it.
They were like, I wonder
if daddy would dress up
and not their dad probably, totally would,
but it was just it totally
got their minds thinking,
like you said there's not a lot of dad,
I really can't...
I thought I was thinking that Nelly knew
that from the Llama Llama series,
there's only one book-
- Yeah.
- that's kind of what the dad,
and they paint this whole thing.
But other than that, I was like,
I don't really know of any.
So it's a really good idea.
And it's so important
'cause father figures
are so important for kids.
And I love Sparkella and I
loved that she tried to fit in
and then she comes back.
Like my kids, I mean,
they're hard on books.
We read every night,
just like you apparently.
And they're hard on books
and they will just walk away.
They'll be like, I'm done,
I just want to go to bed.
(Channing laughs)
Like they can be hard on authors.
I'm like, you're a
critic, but they loved it.
And they were captivated the whole time.
And you did a really good job with it.
- Thank you. That means-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That means a lot to me.
In the same way she
really is hard on books.
She's hard even on me when she was little,
I was trying so hard to be entertaining,
and doing all the voices and everything.
And she'd be like, "Dad, can
you just read it straight?"
- Oh my gosh. Same.
- I just want it straight.
And I'm like, "I've been
training for this my whole life.
And you don't want me to do the voices?"
- Yeah, you didn't like my English accent?
(everybody laughs)
- I was like, look, I'm
never gonna be doing
those accent in the movie.
Let me do it with you.
(Kelly laughs)
(Channing laughs)
- I love it.
- But yeah, I don't know.
She's a hard critic, and
she, like the glitter poop
and stuff like that.
- Glitter poop my kids love.
And we, we really do that and
she found it really funny.
- My kids were cracking up.
My little boy was cracking
up at glitter poop.
He's like, "you said, poop."
He's five.
But anyways, is your
daughter anything like,
are you like the characters?
She's all that kind of sparkle,
rock and roll, little girl walking in?
- Yeah. You know, there
was a really kind of,
where the whole Genesis of the story,
she was in preschool
and she had this like,
she had this watermelon
cape sort of thing,
that when you held your arms out,
it looked like she was
a slice of watermelon
but like when they're down,
she just looked like a cool little cape.
And I remember she loved it,
I don't even know where we got it.
I don't remember buying it.
And she loved it and I
remember the day she put it on
to go to school,
and then when I was like,
"Alright, alright babe,
it's time to go. Let's go."
She like panicked and she
started taking it off,
she's like, "I don't want to wear it,
I don't wanna wear it."
And then I was like, "Wait,
what's what's wrong?"
And she's like, "I don't
want to get made fun of."
And I realized, that
was the very first time
the least that I saw of her
being like self-conscious
about how other people saw her,
and it was like
heartbreaking, but you know,
a beautiful moment all in
one, but she really did.
That was like a small phase
and she really did come out
of any kind of, I think
self consciousness in a way.
She's a little precautious
little tricks too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She's very much like Sparkella,
and I don't know, maybe I
like to wear a fuchsia bow
a little too easily,
maybe I like my nails...
I'm not sure okay.
- But if you pull it
off, you'll put it off.
(both laughs)
- It's fun. Anything that make her laugh,
it's a good idea.
- I love it, I love it.
It's really is a good thing for dads,
it's a really cool thing you're doing.
I have a question, did you...
my mom is an educator.
So like we read a lot when I was a kid.
Did your parents do the same for you?
Is that why you read a lot with her?
- Yeah, my mom read a lot.
My dad worked a lot.
My mom worked too but I think I remember
my mom reading most with me
and they kept all my books.
They were all like, you
know, the golden spine.
- I collect them-
- Yeah, yeah. My daughter
got to read them.
So it was pretty cool,
and it was such a bizarre sort of trip
through memory lane to like open up a book
that you probably didn't see or read.
And like last time, you were
probably eight or seven.
- Yeah.
- And to get to now do it
at 40 was like a really strange like trip.
But yeah, I think they did,
they read a good book to me.
- Yeah. Well, it is lovely
to see you, Channing.
Good luck on the book, it's amazing!
- I'm such a fan of you.
I just want you to know,
I'm so happy that you're doing this-
- Oh, thank you!
- And people are getting
to see you.
I'm like a real fan.
You're such a big heart.
- Ditto. I've been dancing
with you in those movies
for a minute.
(Kelly laughs)
- I wish I could say I've
been singing with you
but I ain't doing that.
- Well now I want a karaoke night.
'Cause the worst people at
karaoke are always my favorite.
Everybody be sure to grab
Channing's new kid's book.
It's called, "The One and Only Sparkella."
It's out right now.
Your kids are going to love it, I promise.
- I heard a little bird told
me that you have a Bronco,
sick, old Bronco.
- I do. It's a 76.
I bought it for my
birthday a few years ago.
Yeah, her name is Dr. Quinn,
because we're forging new
paths in the Western territory.
- Copy that, Dr. Quinn in LA.
- Do you have a Bronco?
- I do now. We did a movie.
I think it was a '87 Bronco
or the one of the big bodies.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And we directed a dog movie this year,
it's gonna come out next year.
And the whole movie is
basically me and a dog
on a road trip in a Bronco.
- Oh my God that sounds awesome
to do with my dog, Henry.
- I see that Bronco behind you.
- Oh it is, yes! That's my Bronco.
- That color only exists in the seventies.
- It's sea foam.
The color is sea foam.
- Oh, sea foam, get that sea foam.
- [Kelly] You know what I
haven't done yet though,
that I'm so excited about,
is I want to take the top off.
And so I'm gonna get something
installed in my garage,
so they'll help lift it up,
'cause it's too hard to do by myself.
- Yeah, it is a pain.
- I've never taken it off.
- I've put one back on.
I haven't taken one off and I was like,
this thing's never coming off again.
To my buddy that I helped,
I was like, or if it does,
don't call me to put it back on.
- Yeah, I'm gonna be honest to you.
And imagine we look
real different Channing.
So if I'm trying to do it...
(both laughs)
I'm like, I'm struggling.
So yeah, I haven't done.
- I was hungover in helping my buddy
and we both were like struggling.
I was like, bro-
- Worst idea.
- I don't want to do this is right now.
Like, this is terrible.